peu
oh
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les niveaux
m
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les vieux manoir
le reste est avec taux plein
je vais donner le baptême de l'air à ta
mère on en a pour dix minutes d'accord
je te laisse aller
haha
et
jacques monod
[Musique]
un param param bada
un patron par les impacts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors alors j'arrive de la clinique oui
alors il sentira et il sait pour jeunes
j'ai essayé lui mentir mais c'était pas
la peine
[Musique]
oui
et
tous gens prier
[Musique]
qui
où
et
e
auray le set est partie ces vêtements
sont plus la silhouette c'est d'abord
l'aviateur tu te suffit que je sois vda
pour qu'ils descendent merde oui
qui sait la famille oui c'est vrai le
député six docteurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur l'année bonjour jérôme monsieur
députés et à table un homme je vous
annonce tout
ne les dérangeait pas surtout c'est
julien je veux voir et tu dois te dire
que tu touches à fait une peur je viens
d'appeler joli tout le monde te cherches
n'a pas l'air d'avoir coupé l'appétit
oui mon fils je viens chercher c'est pas
si ce serait très très politique
[Musique]
julien
julien soirée sonne à 1013 cool et moi
[Musique]
bien
moi julien duquenne
[Musique]
julien
bien pouvoir faut qu'on parle plus d'eux
j'attends papin j'attends je veux plus
te voir
c'est ta phu je veux plus te soit plus
jamais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette comprend ou l'intéressement
c'est encore un enfant edward g semer un
peu de temps temps d'oublier que j'ai
tué ma mère du réseau
[Musique]
je lui laisser le temps tout le temps
qu'il faudra
[Applaudissements]
on va tout va ça dépendra du paysage à
la chan aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à lui mathieu âgé la routine qui me
plaira fait meeddat et plus
[Musique]
allez rennes l'a bien marie aux mines
elle est noyée hier dans la coup de
barre
[Musique]
l'attentât
[Applaudissements]
tiens aux vices
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
d'un coup pour voir mais en douceur
cherchez pas du travail par hasard
pourquoi pas
pourra pas vous donner grand chose mais
pas toujours ça
le gars assez c'est son idée amis moi je
me serais bien comportés les chevaux
cette vigne et les canassons
c'est bon pour la promenade il compte
aujourd'hui et je peux vapeur par once
lucien tu vas pas qu'il est fatigué de
si luciano viendront-elles quoi bon vous
mangez trop saoul précédent coucher chez
nous six matches entre vous plaît ça me
dérange pas de partager que gilles à ton
père il a mangé des rats ou 70 sièges de
paris
un jour raconte façon c'est pas mon vrai
père on va bien je vous donnerai pas ma
mère ne boudèrent l'assistance publique
qui m'a placé chez mathieu de l'unité a
pris le mécanique pensez vous et allez
bouquin pour ça une fois qu'on sait lire
n'y a plus de problème
[Musique]
ouais il vous plaisent pas mais oiseaux
si si mathieu lui les aime points vous
savez pourquoi il a peur que je devienne
pilote
hélas pas tellement tort ça là c'est les
frères wright
ils ont des bonnes gueules non là dessus
ils ont fait 50 mètres avec des chaînes
à vélo lui là c'est le capitaine ferber
il s'est tué il ya six mois au meeting
de boulogne ah oui vous c'est pas ça qui
vous empêchera de voler ben voilà vous
êtes chez vous et toi oh bah moi pour ce
soir je m'arrangerais bien en bas puis
demain on verra clair
j'aurais qui a débarrassé tous à la
question si si j'y tiens mais attention
absolue siens c'est plus marrant il ya
des nuits on a l'impression qu'ils
décollent
non ce que tu faisais avant de venir ici
au un peu tout à part de la prison c'est
pas moi que ça dérange pas été déçu même
si j'avais tué ma femme ça c'est pour
moi
c'est pas une femme qui me le prendre à
ces l'aviation c'est pas vous qui me
diraient le contraire
monsieur dabert j'ai une bonne mémoire
c'est pas comme etienne
pas de photo l'été dans tous les
journaux après l'accident
elle voulait voir comment c'est là haut
il insisté depuis des mois
j'aimerais mieux qu'ils ne sachent pas
d'abord avec un d comme d'habitude c'est
ça oui comme d'habitude toujours rien
monsieur vous y croyez encore
après trois mois à la semaine prochaine
monsieur d'abeilles
[Applaudissements]
allez savoir j'ai eu du mal quand est
arrivé
[Applaudissements]
petit canard aux navets ça vous dirait
pour ce soir meert
chavez situé eà pour une fois on dirait
que madame tuerie a réussi à isoler
d'uranium pur c'est tout l'effet que ça
te fait quoi chavez
jared personne lui a demandé d'être
pilote avec ou sans clous de girofle et
le canard je m'en fout de ton canard
alors avec
[Applaudissements]
on s'en fait tout un monde et c'est pas
plus sorcier que de conduire une
automobile
[Musique]
si un peu
ça lève le nez ou
plein gaz et
à l'école un petit coup de semelle
j'imagine un peu salée
est ce plus rien
allez
[Musique]
mais casse avec les actions tu t'es même
pas que tu parles regarde regarde comme
ça plane et regarde bien ça tombe aussi
mais ça c'est rien il ya même des fois
où ça brûle
qu'est ce qui te prend ses singles et
c'est toi qui me rend cinglé tu
m'emmerdes avec les avions tu comprends
pas d'accord je t'en parle plus mais ça
changera rien un jour je volerais tu
pourras dire ce que tu voudras et
mathieu aussi ça changera rien très bien
molle mais c'est pas faire un enfant
avant c'est tout ce que je te souhaite
[Applaudissements]
g
et
[Musique]
tu as entendu je suis pas sourd
je tienne
il doit rien ce serait même plutôt le
contraire alors si tu décidé de partir
un jour
pour épater tout cas c'est pour toi tu
connais blériot et alors c'est pas le
pas c'est juste le type qui a traversé
la manche
on va peut-être du boulot enfin que tu
pourras toujours essayé je te préviens
ce sera du rail et toi bien une chose
dans ce métier dès qu'on a fait son trou
et plus qu'à mettre une croix dessus
fumer ne vous dérange pas mademoiselle
si justement beaucoup
vous avez entendu
jetez moi cette cochonnerie et puis quoi
encore à cause de cette pimbêche je tais
le nom
alors descendez en marche mais vous êtes
fous choisissez-vous le cigare
[Applaudissements]
marcenais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aux etats unis
dernier arrêt avant paris
[Musique]
la fumée vous dérange vraiment non
politique vous allez à paris oui
dites moi sans indiscrétion vous venez
d'où comme ça du canada du canada c'est
pas la porte à côté ça surtout à votre
âge et vos parents il vous laisse
voyager comme ça tout seul faux badges
journalistes
mon père dirigeait le journal de québec
quand il ya mort j'ai pris la suite
vous dirigez le journal pas toute seule
mon père hier à vannes à ceux ci jugent
pas eu le courage mais si paris mais je
vous croyais pas si vieille j'ai presque
vingt ans vous ne les fait pas
pelé moi c'est parce que je fais un
métier qui conserve amitié vous n'êtes
pas étudiant non enfin j'ai étudié la
mécanique c'est comme ça que j'ai
commencé mais sans la mécanique
j'aurais jamais piloter un avion vous
êtes aviateurs oui je travaille chez
louis blériot vous connaissez ben si je
dois même saveur venons est un des eaux
non non non vous savez moi je n'aime pas
beaucoup la publicité je m'appelle
etienne l'euro oui c'est joséphine le
mieux je vais à paris pour faire lagence
du journal
[Musique]
je m'excuse oui je cherche monsieur
blériot
bien lieu
la base policière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je m'excuse je cherche monsieur blériot
c'est lui là bas dans l'avion
bon bah je vais l'attendre si t'es pas
trop pressé une série de meetings en
europe
ça ne fera jamais que trois semaines à
poireauter à bombay tant pis merci ouais
c'est pour du boulot
oui j'ai une lettre de recommandation de
quai monsieur lucien se voir enfin 10
dont il écrit comme un cochon ton
monsieur lucien je peux louvre et écoute
je m'appelle jules verne on suit pas
aussi célèbre que ton blériot mais je
pourrais peut-être te donner un coup de
main quand même bon
[Applaudissements]
nous de bien avec moi pour ce garçon va
se dépense qu'est ce qu'il sait faire
il a l'air d'avoir de sérieuses
références au nom de dieu et whiskas ce
qu'on l'a vendue à saint gouéno dec
c'est le garage à l'entrée du village il
se fait appeler monsieur lucien
allô oui je voudrais de 259 à boulogne
s'il vous plaît je pourrais pas donné
grand chose ce sera toujours ça m'a post
analyse alain joly
oui c'est bien trop ça lui dis donc on a
retrouvé douar edwards abers tu connais
pas ah la vache
il travaillait sur ce truc avec
béchereau ouais ouais ils se cachent en
bretagne ta voiture est en forme
bon bah tu fais chauffer le moulage
arrive dans une demi heure salut tu va
tâcher de me caler les soupapes du
moteur rotatif là j'ai un lit dans le
bureau et puis j'ai une ardoise au
bistrot alors tu peux y mettre ton dîner
tu viens avec nos jeunes talents je peux
pas il faut que j'essaye le moral bonne
chance petit
quand est-ce que je vais commencer
commencer quoi va travailler mais depuis
ce matin vous n'arrêtez pas vous m'avez
préparer une excellente documentation
sur ces farceurs qui expose aux
indépendants picasso braque delaunay
avait l'air très au courant
j'ai fait une année de beaux-arts
parfait et je crois pas que ce soit des
farceurs le cubisme et une nouvelle
expression une forme révolutionnaire
dollar mademoiselle
ce n'est pas parce que monsieur votre
père pour qui entre parenthèses j'avais
la plus grande estime et est co
directeur du journal de québec que vous
êtes né journalistes
le journalisme est un métier qui
s'apprend et vous êtes venus ici pour la
prendre
on est d'accord bien d'ici quelques
temps je vous confiera des petites
choses de petites choses féminine où la
mode la cuisine mais pour le moment
pour le moment vous me coucherai tout ce
qui a trait à la chambre tenait et vous
me ferez également un petit résumé du
discours de brillants que je vois de
quoi vous êtes capables vous n'avez pas
fait les sciences politiques par hasard
dommage à demain vous laisserez la clé
chef concierge monsieur si on téléphone
ne vous inquiétez pas mal aux ailes
personne ne téléphonera
et si le journal de québec bureau de
paris oui c'est moi c'est vous ça vous
dirait qu on dîne ensemble voilà je suis
encore au terrain mais je pourrais vous
prendre dans un petit quart d'heure
je vous préviens si vous venez en avion
il a banni mandala raymond barre vous
inquiétez pas à gérer non non c'est
impossible
ah bon j'ai beaucoup de travail ce soir
au fond ça tombe bien moi aussi en voir
mademoiselle au revoir
on travaille pour l'instant master là
vous avez une autorisation
bien sûr vous ne manquerez si vous
voulez
tu peux bien ça
pour nous
merci le royaume c'était pour le plaisir
je m'appelle ans
moix etienne ces petits curieux voulait
prendre des photos de nouveaux modèles
dites moi c'est comme ça tous les soirs
heureusement tu vois ce petit ce qu'elle
est il n'a l'air de rien comme ça
c'est pourtant ce qui les intéresse
alors ils essayent de prendre quelques
petits photo tiens voilà la maquette qui
peut la tenir et c'est une cellule
monocoque
quand il sera terminé il ne leur a pas
plu le câblage que les nerfs sur le pôle
le vent glissera des sous comme cela
copil de 9
autrement dit il volera plus vite en se
fatiguant moins exact il y en a beaucoup
qui n'y croient pas
ça leur paraît trop beau pour être vrai
mais ça le chatouille quand même alors
il se renseigne comme ils peuvent
k o il est la chance de travailler
là-dessus aux attendes s'est pas encore
fait faudra d'abord que je cafouille pas
trop avec les superbes de ce machin
c'est un examen d'entrée j'ai drôlement
la trouille j'ai calé la 2 avant le
dîner laisse moi regarde et attend non
c'est pas bon du tout ne peut aller
avant tout tu prends papier peut caler
entre le clapet ton un peu oui
stop en avant l' le bouge plus il faut
que les papiers sont caressés sans être
maqué là
voilà c'est bon sinon la traque à
claques et des chevaux à de l'oreille
avec lui c'est pas au millimètre et
c'est au centième de millimètre tient à
toi maintenant formidable vous êtes
ingénieur non plus l'autre ça ne se voit
pas je devais disputer la coupe
michelard mais j'ai cassé mon sens doit
cesser j'irai pas en allemagne demain
matin les mécanos c'est l'ange gardien
de pilotes ne l'oubliez jamais chaque
fois que tu dis que tu risques et à vie
oui je sais dans ce métier quand tu as
fait ton trou il n'y a plus qu'à mettre
une croix dessus
tu connais et loire monsieur dabert oui
mais je pense bien gelée quitté hier
matin
bon dieu où se cachent que c'est déjà
dur
[Musique]
un orage est ferme et messieurs c'est
bien ici que travail monsieur dabert
qu'il travaillait il est parti hier
vous savez où il me l'a pas dit mais
vous avez bien une petite idée quand
même à vous savez la france et ses
grands et puis si ça lui suffit pas bas
il ya tout le reste
achim d'angleterre et l'amérique du sud
[Musique]
où
fraîchement et la porte
[Applaudissements]
non non peut-être pu faire tourner avant
de partir parce que ta chambre c'est
aussi mon bureau tu as une fille dans la
peau quoi mais enfin merde tu te
regardes et tu as les yeux là tu verrais
pas la fin d'une vis de 12 écoute
etienne où tu travailles avec moi ou pas
parce que ça fait un mois que ça dure et
moi j'en ai marre
moi aussi j'en ai marre je pêchereau est
drôlement je veux bien travailler à la
gueule mais pour ce prix là je me
laisserais pas engueulé vous croyez que
ça m'amuse dub lever tous les matins à 5
heures et de me taper la 30 ans beckham
jusqu'à paris pour distribuer des
journaux
et tout ça pour 20 euros des journaux
oui des journaux il faut bien que je
paye matin on est dans un temps moi
aussi et puis les cigarettes c'est pour
ma pomme
ml kate et mes godasses et ma brosse à
dents ça et penser à ma brosse à dents
non il reste du café au pied n'est pas
vous imaginer que je le fais pour vous
je le ferais même pas pour moi mais pour
votre [ __ ] l'avion je le fais parce
que je voudrais le voir voler il va
voler s'énerve pas non merci j'ai déjà
des jeunes est assez des excuses que tu
veux bon ben
eh ben je les fais voilà etien n'est
même pas de sucre dans votre chicorée
hendaye en attendant le sucrier non plus
il est bientôt falloir que je paie le
sucre aussi euros dis donc 200 francs
par mois ça tire et ça bien sûr je peux
pas que les données
tu le sais bien ah oui alors eh bien
alors on additionne des salaires et puis
si ça marche je te pète tout en arrière
et d'un coup non mais attends attends le
travail c'est de l'argent que tu
investis et que mme aucun placement se
fait sans intérêt moi je te propose je
sais pas moi 5% sur les bénéfices voilà
ben en attendant je peux continuer à
vendre mes journaux ça te rapporte
combien ça vingt six par jour un souk va
je me débrouillerai pour teulet donnait
un vin sous par jour
monsieur v chaud et c'est moi ça fait
longtemps je voulais bavarde avec vous
permettez je me présente armand des
perdus ça je suis financier etienne une
chaise pour monsieur d'un an c'est pas
la peine on parle beaucoup de vous
monsieur béchereau en ce moment beaucoup
on dirait que ça prend forme
c'est pour aller plus vite évidemment
évidemment j'ai toujours pensé que le
mot n'était pas incompatible avec le
fonctionnel je veux dire la rentabilité
vous m'aviez compris entre est bien mais
j'ai très bien compris
1 vous pouvez parler devant monsieur
lourd c'est mon thé mon associé vous
soyez pas contre éventuellement de
vendre votre avion en série faudrait
d'abord qu'ils volent
là il volera pas sans argent je me suis
laissé dire qu'il y avait une saisie en
cours contre eux même pas ça je vous
remercie je suis déjà au courant
l'huissier s'est dérangé en personne
mais pourquoi pas régler ces petits des
classes et l'absurde et vous proposez
quoi une association 51% des peurs pour
qui pour vous c'est la majorité c'est
qu'à chaque fois ça
rien absolument rien joue dessus non
soyons sérieux vous demandez quand même
quelque chose en échange
pas grand chose entre nous je serai
flatté qu'un autre avion porte mon nom
et voilà comment vous expliquez ça sans
être pompeux je serais content que mon
nom soit porté sur des ailes et ben moi
aussi figurez vous voulez pas que cet
enfant là dans le vent est encore jeune
béchereau il en volera plein db trop
qu'apporte-t-il
premier est un peu batteur jamais de la
vie vous m'entendez jamais à je m'y
attendais réfléchissez tenez voilà ma
carte
si je ne suis pas chez moi vous ne
trouverez en gare au casino à bientôt
monsieur b chaud c'est ça à bientôt
gens retournent au casino
[Applaudissements]
mais ils démarrent pas fort mon petit
placement dimanche prochain c'est le
départ de la course paris madrid
oui je sais c'est le petit parisien
qu'il organise ça devrait intéresser
nous lecteurs la première grande course
internationale de l'histoire de
l'aviation
nous enverrons à montréal un condensé
des informations publiées par le petit
parisien
pourquoi ne pas faire nous mêmes le
reportage mademoiselle je ne suis pas un
spécialiste en aéronautique
je pourrais peut-être meurthe et moselle
je vais l'aviation est une affaire
d'hommes
pourtant avec la relation que j'ai ici
les minots à etienne le roux vous
connaissez non ce qui j'ai oublié vous
que des séries à la vie aussi vous avez
entendu parler du bio bien sûr le pilote
c'est etienne je vous suggère un
reportage en trois parties les
préparatifs de la course la course
elle-même le vainqueur je serais pas
étonné que ce week-end
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai le goût
[Musique]
avant que si
étienne roeckel à eau à non pour lui
c'est d'amos etienne il est là-bas wydad
et le voilà qui arrive
[Rires]
je vois vraiment pas ce cas-ci drôle
d'accord je vais raconter des histoires
n'empêche qu'un jour je volerais avec sa
voix ça c'est un pingouin un pingouin
oui un truc pour apprendre quoi c'est
dommage cette course paris madrid aurait
pu faire mon premier reportage et vous
comptiez sur le grand pilote et yen
l'euro pour vous passer les tuyaux
je vais vous arranger ça
c'est davos
c'est sa gauche un jour on est inscrits
tous les trois pour la course
combien de conquérant on en prévoit une
vingtaine et de plusieurs nationalités
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils soient tous au
départ ce trop casse gueule moi c'est ma
première grande course comme pilote mais
ça ne lui fait pas peur aussi combien
d'étapes 4 paris angoulême angoulême san
sebastien san sebastien burgos burgos
madrid
la date du départ historique le dimanche
11 mai 1911
[Musique]
c'est une bougie ce peut-être le gicleur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
passera pas parce qu en parle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans et doit c'est pas vrai a dit non
c'est pas l'endroit idéal pour se poser
un j'étais bien content de les trouver
figure toi qu'est ce que tu fous au
milieu de ces montagnes tu es devenu
ermite hannon mécano en prévision des
petits compagne qui tombera du ciel pour
demander un coup de main alors tu as
fait ton diagnostic c'est l'arrivée
d'essence je crois mais on peut aller
voir j'ai pris mon matériel bons ballons
tu fais paris madrid tu lis les journaux
quand même tu poses et combien on
voulait troisième nom et davos ont des
banques d'une voix passé penses tu je
vous prie par le bord de mer sont moins
cours eux je suis même plusieurs une
boussole train si tu es si ma langue
fall est aligné au départ
en tout cas c'est une panne que je ne
regretterai pas si on se dépêcha
peut-être encore une chance j'étais en
lan quand c'est arrivé le temps de vie
ni à paris qui était déjà reparti je te
reprocher rien moi aussi tu aurais pu
m'attendre
c'est joli qui m'a raconté tant mieux ça
m'évitera de recommencer
c'est pas parce que je t'ai vu que tu
dois encore déménagé ton adresse g l'a
déjà oublié
si on parlait un peu de toi pour changer
moi on marche je suis deux maintenant
mari a été tendue dont c'est aussi
l'avis de matha on s'est connu à l'école
communale
quand tu vois il a de la suite dans les
idées il faut que tu viens nous voir en
allemagne et je suis sûr que tu tu
entendras bien avec ma tête aussi en
titre que toi aller là je crois que ça
va aller
bon
venez lice pour la course tu comprends
avec un grand pas mais pour la montagne
c'était pas assez alors j'ai triché sur
le réglage de l'allumage
je t'ai mis une de plus comme ça le
moteur va tourner plus vite tu comprends
ouais bon mais va falloir que tu te
dépêches parce que le temps va se gâter
je ne veux pas monter voir je porte pas
chance tu sais ça fait rien je suis pas
superstitieux
contact contact
solidaires
ben oui
enfin
et julia
keyyo est en cours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ne quittez pas monsieur je vais voir
monsieur julien c'est votre père
monsieur julien n'est pas là monsieur
qui s 0 c'est monsieur kader passé deux
mois ne quittez pas monsieur un instant
à l'eau edwards
vous venez manger doit alors vieille ça
va être froid
julien le tenant pour responsables de
l'accident d'avion qui a coûté la vie à
sa mère edwards a bear décide de rompre
à tout jamais avec l'aviation et
disparaît dans le garage de province où
il travaille incognito il se lie
d'amitié avec etienne le roux un jeune
mécano qui rêvent de voler
muni d'une lettre de recommandation
d'edouard etienne s'embarque pour issy
les moulineaux dans le train il fait la
connaissance de joséphine le mieux une
jeune journaliste canadienne engagée par
l'ingénieur louis béchereau etienne fait
son apprentissage de rampan sur un avion
monocoque de conception révolutionnaire
quelques mois plus tard la course paris
madrid donne l'occasion à edward abers
de retrouver son vieil ami ans master en
panne dans les pyrénées
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à quelques hommages j'aurais dû emmener
mon fils il est passionné d'aviation
mais regardez ça c'est merveilleux non
autres à vue là les charognards
[Musique]
alors on y va quand vous voulez monsieur
commissaire si vous tenez à respecter
l'heure légale il s'en fout encore de 30
secondes
désolé de vous contredire ou retardés
[Musique]
bon allons-y
j'ai l'impression qu'il ne vous reste
pas grand-chose à saisir le fourbe
il a filé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouaddou semences et fragile au bilan
mais les fans sont lâchés de chansons
apprises ou et mathieu qui la chantait
tout le temps à la forge c'est qu'il en
a vu de la misère lui dans les années 80
riba te fais pas d'illusions on va en
voir aussi nous et dans les années 11
vous êtes bien cafard de monsieur louis
france tu fous de joie
c'est idéal pour à l'ingénieur d'aller
se mettre au vert pour construire des
avions
et si je modifie les codes d'une pièce
moi je vais la faire usines et où et les
essais en admettant qu'on soit pas en
prison d'ici là on les fera dans les
betteraves dire qu'on va on va
travailler en cachette comme si on
faisait de la fausse monnaie
c'est peut-être justement parce ça qu'il
faudrait commencer à faire de la fausse
monnaie et le type qui est venu nous
voir l'autre jour là comment il
s'appelle déjà
des pères du saint ce vautour
plutôt crever
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu sais tienne tu ferais bien de
chercher une place ailleurs
maintenant que t'es débrouillé je suis
sûr que blériot voisin de prendre et
c'est pas bon faire les cons que le soir
je tenais déjà dit on voit tout en noir
oui mais quand je les fais le matin ça
me coupe les bras pour la journée un
maquis dont tu vas voir joséphine toi
non pourquoi
après je suis pas dit fait tellement
beau alors je peux pas mettre une
cravate à les voir josephy ya pas qu
elle sur la place de paris
heureusement à êtes fâché non mais ça
fait quand même deux mois qu'on se voit
pas j'en avais marre d'entendre parler
du social tout le temps la politique la
politique ya quand même autre chose dans
la vie non à quoi tu penses exactement à
cet autre truc qui a dans la vie
justement et elle n'est pas d'accord
pour sa figure toi j'ai prêté lui
demander eh ben tu as peut-être eu tort
alors on voit bien que tu la connais pas
venu quand même bonne nuit louis
[Musique]
ger servir ce bandeau de ce soir et et
or ni son départ du train oui c'est vrai
oui ne reconnaissait pas si si si vous
êtes l'associé de biche oh oh qu'est ce
que vous faites là je vous attendais
team très bien mademoiselle aussi billes
danseuse monsieur etienne leroux
aviateurs 7 bussereau qui vous en veux
non c'est une idée à moi qu'est ce que
vous diriez d'un petit déjeuner au
muscadet avec 18 hrs non vous êtes
gentil ça risquerait de mettre en retard
si ça vous dérange pas vous pourriez me
raccompagner à issy les moulineaux on
discutera de tout ça en route comme vous
voulez genre on ne rentre pas couché
on a toute la journée pour se
dit je mets ma bécane dans la voiture et
aux allemands
victoire aux blessés la voiture et vous
rentrez chez vous par vos propres moyens
non non non non non non la seconde
derrière allez
[Musique]
mais doucement attention marot on y va
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
connais tu arrivé au restaurant qu'ils
dorent d'or maudites d'or en définitive
quel est votre avis je voudrais pas
m'avancer trop mais je suis pas sûr à
100% mais maintenant j'ai l'impression
que monsieur bergeron pourrait se
laisser tenter par votre proposition
j'avais les ordres à la longue on s'y
habitue
mais à la fin on s'en lasse et puis je
pense pas que vous soyez un type comme
ça
un type comme en a comme dit monsieur
béchereau une espèce de vautours qui
pensent qu'au pognon
[Applaudissements]
vous avez volé alors parce que
l'occasion s'est jamais présenté à oui
mais c'est jamais la fille qui fait le
premier pas vous devez savoir ça mieux
que moi alors si vous l'aimez faudra
vous déclarez vous avez un moment
alors ça y est je crois qu'il a mordu tu
crois qu'il va grimper
ah oui il en meurt d'envié fais gaffe
aux est un gars je te confie wake ou tu
t'en fais donc pas là elle est pas là
bussereau ah non les chevaux il est en
exil
justement à cause des types comme vous
qui veulent mettre leur nom sur son
avion ça gênerait pas de battre le chien
sur mon argent ça si c'est votre idée
bon moi en attendant il faut que j'aille
le retrouver mais je trop parce que j'ai
du boulot
attendez je suis avec vous
je vous préviens j'ai été lâché il ya
huit jours j'ai que trois heures de vol
bon allez on y va c'est qu'il fait très
froid la haute joaillerie goulard étiez
votre chien par dessus cette fois
cependant les la casquette comme ça
comme ça à papa travaille à casquette
d'abord il faut que j'aille à mon boulot
moi on est pressé la maison oui bah vous
installé sur le siège avant
mais mon chéri tu vas monter là dedans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah bah ouais décidément il est doué ce
môme encore un petit mois il sera en
coin et moi alors qu'est ce que je
deviens dans tout ça et qu'est ce que
vous diriez d'un petit café
laissez vous faire nous sommes des
gentlemans mardan scala
je
alors peur
non mais là
fantastique
sensationnel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non mais ça va plus mais ça va plus du
tout la tête mais décidément tu déconnes
à plein tube toi
et vous qu'est ce que vous foutez là
vous êtes complètement foot de voler
avec ce dingue faut faire joujou avec
les avions c'est dangereux ces trucs là
me l'a jamais dit vous n'avez pas comme
ça mais je trouve jamais cru que je vous
soyez pas fâchés de me voir c'est tout
qui mois alors là ça me ferait mal
puis je vous préviens pour rentrer vous
allez prendre le début ça parce que ce
taxi l'a aidé colmatant vous et si
quelqu'un vient ici un duché pointe son
nez
j'aurai besoin de personne pour casser
la gueule inquiétez pas il est un peu
soupe au lait mais ça s'arrangera
elle est grave vous touchez à rien elle
défense de monter dedans ou les cons
bien sûr fallait faire ensemble
- ouais non non rien je suis en contact
monsieur b choix vous m'attendais une
petite seconde bac tu es saucisson vin
blanc tout le tremblement mais je
n'oublie pas les prisonniers monsieur
besson les adore ça ne parlait pas trop
de fric ça lui hérisse le poil alors là
tu remarques un avion figure toi ça se
voit de loin dans moins d'une heure on
va voir les journalistes et la marée
choisis sur le dos je prends tout sur
moi monsieur le roulis est absolument
pour rien au monde l'oeil lui pleurs
après son petit mois et à les dons et
s'ils étaient moins combo s'il tenait
simplement avoir votre espèce de machine
en l'air après tout les faits pour ça
non si vous étiez moins tu es tu déjà pu
gagner la course paris madrid 1 non mais
vous rêvez là c'est vous le rêveur c'est
à se demander si vous n'avez pas peur
d'un échec
bon ça va ça va vous amener du nouveau
cru j'ai volé et alors vous croyez que
ça m'épate
et comment toi ta gueule à part ça à
part ça mes conditions restent les mêmes
ah c'est une bonne idée
cette petite balade va creuser et ben je
vous laisse continuer bon appétit
merci beaucoup nivière semble à mon avis
pour s'en sortir au début il faudrait
tabler sur trois appareils par mois
ah ouais et voulait vendre un acquis
pourquoi pas l'armée vous savez aussi
bien que moi que les militaires n'y
croit pas vraiment le député brisseau il
croit suffisamment pour les convaincre
le député brisseau c'est un ami à vous
le député brisseau j'ai fait quelques
petites affaires avec lui et vous croyez
qu'ils vous donnant la main je serais
bien surpris qu'il refuse une petite
commission au passage
tiens voilà ça commence
et celui-là pas la peine de demander si
c'est un pisse copie bonjour monsieur
peu trop je suis reporter à naître en
moi j'étais bien que je vous trouve à
dans le coin mais sans cet avion je vous
aurais jamais trouvé bon bah fout le
camp
soyez chic quoi monsieur bussereau juste
un mot ou de rien pas ça pourquoi pas un
peu plus publicité fera pas de mal à la
spad un spad ah oui la société de
production des appareils des paires du
sein est alors bien sûr à vous le
regretterez pas mon vieux on va faire de
grandes choses ensemble des shows france
angers udine et ça fait plus d'une
semaine que je tournicoter dans le coin
fait semblant de traquer s'il vous plaît
mabiala toi ne bougeront plus encore une
s'il vous plaît entre nous monsieur
béchereau ce que vous allez courir le
circuit européen
prudemment alors là pas question j'aime
autant vous le dire tout de suite
vous savez ce que ces circuits 9 étapes
plus de 15 100 km avec la traversée de
la manche aller retour et nous on sait
même pas si on on peut voler jusqu'au
bout du champ les cinq premiers se
partageront 220 mille francs et alors
vous avez pas versé un rang et vous
pensez déjà vous rembourser nos monts
quand je me lancerai dans une épreuve
comme ça j'aurais fait des essais des
vrais avec un pilote de première un type
qui sera roderick appareils reprenez la
pause s'il vous plaît
le monocoque des perdus ça ne
participera pas au grand circuit urbain
demandé l'intransigeant l'ingénieur
bussereau déclare forfait deux modèles
transigeant l'ingénieur bussereau
déclare au fait de mode et
l'intransigeant l'ingénieur avait choisi
leur forfait de seconde au code des
pères du sein ne participant pas aux
grands circuits en bien
[Musique]
attention dans quelques secondes
départ de renault et se joue sur goudron
biplan
[Musique]
la fin
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
j'en viens maintenant c'est fini c'est
papa yang environ puisque ton père me
dit que c'est le dernier à les voir on
n'a pas vu aussi comme ça c'est quand
même curieux que quelqu'un ne sont pas
là
sur quelle tête là vous en faites par
man on sera fin prêt pour courir la
prochaine et or là on va les enterrer
tous vous verrez
mais chaud
bonjour ça va rarement bonjour en plus
avaient très bien fait de vous laisser
pousser la moustache n'est ce pas alors
vous me montrerez quand ce fameux
monocoque j'espérais un peu le voir
là-haut ou jamais que pour moi il n'y a
pas de secret d'état
l'avenir de l'aviation c'est l'armée
n'oubliez jamais ça à condition qu'il y
ait la guerre
je ne le souhaite pas mais rien
n'empêche de la préparer vous me
comprenez si tu veux la paix prépare la
guerre
c'est ma forme et armand vous le dira
les derniers continueront le déjà
célèbre à jules vernon sur podologie 3
est la surprise du jour
le monocoque des pierres du sein il
disparaît ken le rouge
vous n'êtes qu'à fous criminels
écoutez moi je vais tous vous explique
[Applaudissements]
lâchez-moi espèce de faux jetons
écoutons mal oui nous avons notre chance
étienne maladie etienne mais vous en
foutez pas mal détiennent il faut bien
se casser la gueule et anna non chez moi
et puis des membres enchères vous avez
le goût du risque
elles font les fous mais ce fut ma
pauvre
ouais
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
opa qui décolle faut l'empêcher de
décoller il est bon et a volé c'est trop
tard mais non même et fait quelque chose
qu'il faut l'empêcher nord
et qu'est ce que c'est mais seront
gelées seront pas voyons non
[Musique]
en maison d'arrêt
allez mon sens
monte
[Musique]
jules il décolle adieu les décotes chili
d'école
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh non merde alors merde m'a fait rater
mans décollage
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis il ya nos voisins
ces poudres hossa et ben ça mon vieux
c'est une monocoque de départ du sein
par actus rigole il n'a jamais volé en
tout cas ils étaient prescrits
à
3h09 aux sachets plus en moyenne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu promets vernon s'est posée depuis
longtemps on l'attend 1
mais oui il est derrière toi ça ne
m'étonnerait pas que tu es fait le
meilleur temps
q uand tes pères du saint remporte à la
première étape du ce
[Applaudissements]
monsieur blon pourquoi vous avez coupé
leur nuage
[Applaudissements]
tiens et elle est grave pour toi il doit
être fumé le patron que pamiers et ses
[Applaudissements]
félicitations
non c'est pas ça bravo est pas ça non
plus quelle merveilleuse exploit c'est
pas ça non plus bas abbassi voilà voilà
sale petit con entêté stop
félicitations et augmentation stop
seront cologne tâche d'être à l'heure
béchereau des pères du saint
[Applaudissements]
et joséphine
[Musique]
ces gars
ouah
bah
les chevaliers du mauss de bois
[Musique]
à
moi
même pas
[Musique]
à
tombe en pleine descente c'était
épouvantable il prépare pendant un an et
il n'avait pas assez d'essence pour
faire tomber en panne au boulot oui je
suis content pour toi c'est pas moi
qu'il faut féliciter mais notre pilote
etienne alors je suis en forme et cielo
des nouvelles d'edward abbey 1 et n'ont
toujours aucune ethnie fola bonjour
aujourd'hui
bonjour bonjour monsieur amour des
plantes et notre financiers et amis es
asseyez vous monsieur merci en france
qu'est ce que tu fabriques ici moi je te
préviens berlin était ce matin on
travaille sur une grille plana avec un
tony vous êtes ingénieur également
j'essaye en allemagne on parle plus que
de vous elle nous a coupé les bras tu
vois ce que c'est la jalousie
on est venu voir si on ne pouvait pas
aboutir un petit monocoque ce sera pas
la peine parce que j'ai cassé mon train
en posant il fallait voir le terrain
aussi un c'était un vrai bourbier pas
pour vernon pas pour beaumont
vous avez combien d'heures de vol
monsieur leroux 15 mai en comptant celle
du circuit mais j'ai bien peur que la
coque en ai pris un sacré coup aussi et
alors on va toute la nuit devant nous
vous acceptez la main d'oeuvre étrangère
avant naturellement
à ce 14e place maintenant c'est pas
votre jour de chance mon cher joly
aujourd'hui à témoin on en fait une
petite annonce dans le genre du g20 ce
qui se passe dans l'ordre il dort comme
un bébé
eh bien il prend des réserves il sera
prêt pour le grand départ l'intérieur
la chine peut pas la rater
ouverte
bon voilà
et pour moi a réussi à décoller avec le
temps c'est pas de la tarte
c'est pas raisonnable et une autre en
rester là
bah merde pour trois gouttes de pluie
qu'est ce que tu en penses
je n'ai plus un match tu es où l'apport
d'accord
j'ai perdu cinq ont pas eu d abord le
jure
attends attends au débat
hélène lérou ses opposants que tu es
certain
parfaite toujours karim dents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merde
[Musique]
donc
monde
[Musique]
m
coc
[Musique]
et
hautmont
[Musique]
m
temps
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
à côté
tous
[Musique]
oh
bah
[Musique]
e
excuse pour la peau chercher
[Musique]
un travail est encore à cette heure ci
allez venez je connais un bistrot il ya
les meilleurs escargots de paris vous
démange ray tout seul vous escarmouches
et pas livré à temps de votre boulot
personnes en moi mais ça se peut pas
vous rester des mois sans donner signe
de vie mais il faudrait que ce soit la
bonne disposition le jour où ça vous
chante
et il faudrait que j'aime les escargots
en plus vous êtes bien nerveuse
aujourd'hui et l'interview exclusive que
votre monsieur bayrou a accordé à ce
crétin de l'intrant l'inventeur de
l'avion du siècle et son fidèle mécano
mystérieusement disparue depuis des
semaines ça vous aurait fait mal de me
le passé studio 1
et vous ça vous aurait fait mal de
m'envoyer un télégramme quand je me suis
posé à liège
tout le monde m'a félicité sauf
mademoiselle le mieux et moi là où comme
un con je pensais qu'à vous faut bien
penser à quelque chose
j'ai bien d'autres soucis n'ont d'abord
mon boss et puis vous tue ce qu'il
faisait à fait votre patron les avances
si avec ça
regardez ce qui m'a dicté je voudrais
que je transmets de sa marianne jadis
les brigands à cheval se contentait de
dévaliser le paisible voyageurs de nos
jours les bandits en automobile n'hésite
pas à bad froidement un inoffensif
garçons payeurs mais que le tueur de la
rue ordener prenne garde point
d'exclamation mademoiselle la justice
sera plus rapide que leurs engins à
moteur et tous les citoyens à se
dresseront comme un seul homme pour dire
non en majuscules mademoiselle non à la
canaille qui déshonorent notre
civilisation
vous appelez ça de la formation vous
c'est tout juste si les traite pas de
bêtes sauvages
mais dites moi
cette encaisseur ils lui ont tiré dessus
quand même d'accord il faudra peut-être
savoir pourquoi
pour lui voler sa sacoche tient etienne
vous serez que derrière chaque fait
divers il y as fait social un fait
politique
la police n'ose pas la nette mais moi ça
ne m'étonnerait pas que des anarchistes
derrière tout ça mais zannah je crois
qu'ils avaient disparu depuis le temps
comment voulez vous être au courant les
journaux font tout pour laisser le
peuple dans l'ignorance
ça tient toujours cette invitation à
dîner et comment le tabac du coin est
encore ouvert aller nous chercher de la
bière et des sandwichs people que ce que
vous attendez je meurs de faim avant mon
bon le peuple s'exécute
au pâté de campagne et du camembert et
voila voila quoi j'ai refait l'arte que
moi-même ses bras de fer qui vous a mis
ces idées là dans la tête il était
comment votre ferr bon intelligent
tolérant passionnés terriblement obstiné
féroce c'était un dreyfusards très
engagée s'est fait beaucoup d'ennemis et
il m'a toujours dit qu'il fallait
défendre ses idées même si c'était pas
très confortable où c'est pourquoi je
vais envoyer mon papier à montréal et
n'ont pas signé serez vous allez avoir
des ennuis et alors n'avait pas demandé
la permission vous pour faire le cercle
rien et vous
vous m'aviez pas dit vous étiez à
l'arrivée à vincennes moi j'étais
menteuse je vous ai vus aux actualités
alors rien bon si vous voulez que votre
article par cette nuit il faut se manier
[Musique]
m
bon d'un bon soir joséphine vous venez
prendre un verre avec plaisir
[Musique]
on
mademoiselle le mieux ici c'est une
maison respectable les visites
masculines sont formés maguin dit je
vous laisse pas question se livrerait
pas trop plaisir et vient pas on s'en
bat l'oeil brillant
si c'est pas une honte a décidé de me
tutoyer
cette chaîne
[Musique]
voyons etienne sont pas hypocrite on
trouvera jamais mieux pour passer la
nuit
moi aussi j'ai froid et moi aussi j'ai
mal aux pieds et moi aussi j'ai envie
d'être près de toi
[Musique]
tu permets
là
[Musique]
e
non
ouais
m
e
[Musique]
il
tu veux parler ton manteau
[Musique]
bicycle vraiment c'est pas possible
comprendre ce pas
je comprends très bien
toutes les idées affranchissez rien que
des paroles chez toi tout se passe ici
alors t'étonne pas si tu restes vieille
fille oui c'est ça s'en va lorsqu'on a
de mieux à faire
[Applaudissements]
au revoir messieurs dames à la prochaine
fois nous sommes vous occupez vous de ce
qui vous regarde
[Applaudissements]
à issy les moulineaux j'ai dit à votre
carnation de ce manuel fin on aurait dit
ça ya six mois je n'aurais jamais cru
voir et les caisses kitsch iphone encore
les factures obtenues temps fou des
factures mais moi ça me démolit et
pourquoi tu t'inquiètes puisque toute
façon ces deux pères du saint qui les
paye non à condition qu'ils soient là
pour signer l'échec parce que figure
fois qu'il a disparu depuis trois
semaines mais c'est normal il est
toujours fourré en province pour ses
affaires pensez à faire mais je me
demande bien ce qu'ils trafiquent celui
là et puis c'est pas tout fabriquer des
avions à qui on va les vendre à l'armée
tu sais bien t'as pas lu le dernier
discours de bruit sourd à la chambre
elle m'a bien je vais montrer ça
[Musique]
et là j'ai souligné ce qui nous
intéresse la en temps de guerre
l'aéroplane sera utilisé comme appareil
d'observation le farman et le voisin
semble particulièrement adapté à ce
genre de mission mehdi dont il nous
laisse tomber ce [ __ ] bassam en a tout
l'air
[Applaudissements]
enfin il n'y a pas que les militaires
quand même un bon et qui à quoi ça c'est
un avion tu t'es déjà posé la question à
rien il ya les courses les meetings mais
je suis pas un homme de cire points
ainsi je travaille c'est pour qu'un jour
on puisse transporter des gens en
amérique en afrique au pôle nord partout
ils voudront aller partout il y aura
sept places pour poser une roue ouais on
a le temps louis laisse faire les choses
at a peut-être raison
et à propos avec joséphine ça s'est
arrangé je vois pas le rapport
ah non je te jure je vois vraiment pas
le rapport à il me semble qu'il faut pas
laisser faire les choses toujours et que
si j'étais à ta place et ben moi je lui
téléphonerait robin il va toujours se
brosser tiens c'est certainement pas moi
qui ferai le premier pas non mais même
pas le courage de vos actes vous auriez
pu au moins signé de votre nom mais il
l'aurait pas publiés c'est un véritable
abus de confiance mademoiselle le mieux
depuis la mort de mon père le journal
qui a créé n'ose plus dire la vérité
j'ai voulu changer tout ça même une fois
vérité quelle vérité à vous entendre ces
bandits sont des victimes
il cède des bombes y fabrique de la
fausse monnaie d'accord ils seront
peut-être sur la façon de faire mais au
moins ils refusent une société qui leur
offrent des mensonges
décidément vous êtes bien jeune dommage
je commençais à m'habituer à vous
j'ignore si le journal voudra vous
employez ailleurs c'est leur affaire
mais moi je me vois obligé de me passer
vos services vous y attendiez je suppose
à partir de quand à partir de tout de
suite
naturellement vous pas votre billet de
retour
je vais vous faire un mot pour l' agence
havas je peux vous donner un conseil
prenez le premier bateau pour le canada
et si j'ai envie de rester à paris moi
j'ai une oreille à la préfecture je n'ai
pas voulu vous en parler mais les
contacts que vous avez avec les milieux
extrémistes ont posé une fâcheuse
impression quand vous êtes étrangères je
pourrais devenir indésirables c'est ça
on n'aura pas besoin de me renvoyer vous
pourrez lui dire à votre oreille je suis
très contente de partir je vois vraiment
pas ce qui pourrait me retenir encore à
paris
[Applaudissements]
nous
impossible
pas partir comme ça tout de suite
[Musique]
allô allô
de ce dépôt d'espèces de baby à jouer
l'espagne
je voudrais parler à monsieur leroux
s'il vous plaît les palois
essais libres et non oui et j'ai le
numéro marché
alors c'est très très urgent je voudrais
issy les moulineaux le 245
alors on va rater votre autre avant moi
même un chien jeu alors je voudrais
parler et une rousse nous plaît c'est
impossible nous elle jette en l'air
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non non il n'y a pas de message
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
et
oui
[Musique]